hey everybody what's up this is ian this
is my msx story
obviously there's been a ton of stuff
that's happened this year it's been one
of the best years of my life but i think
one of the more memorable
experiences that i've had on campus was
getting to work for an entire quarter
on my writing skills glenn kramon is one
of my favorite professors here
he was an editor at the new york times
for over 25 years under his tutelage
he nurtured 10 different journalists who
all um won a pulitzer prize so
getting to spend an entire quarter
working on my writing skills was really
fun
specifically he helped me critique a
speech from my friend who's getting
married this summer
and it went from not very funny to
really funny um and that's largely on on
behalf of glenn so
moving forward working with glenn
craymon on my writing is gonna help me
because i think writing is one of the
most fundamental skills in business
and it's also something that i like to
do on the side creatively you know
having not really spent any time on it
since college getting getting to really
go deep with someone who's an expert
has really enhanced i think my ability
to communicate my feelings my thoughts
in a concise and clear way
and it's just been a really fun
experience
you